Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vouset activez la petite cloche !
Salut les Épicurieux.
Vous connaissez ce légume ?
C'est untopinambour,
un tubercule.
Ça pousse dans le sol,
comme une pomme de terre,
accrochéà une racine.
Ce n'est d'ailleurs pas leur seul point commun.
Les deux viennent dunouveau monde
mais pourquoi « topinambour » ?
Ce tubercule débarque dans les ports français,
au début du XVII ème siècle.
Il vient du Canada
où il est baptisé jusqu'alors
« artichaut d'hiver ».
Aumême moment,
six membres d'une tribu brésilienne
sont embarqués de force sur un navire
pour êtreprésentés au Roi de France,
Louis XIII.
Ces deux événements font grand bruit
dans les villages età la campagne.
Ils vont se percuter et se mélanger.
Les nouveaux venus à la cour,
appartiennent à latribu
« des Toüoupinambaoults ».
J'espère que je prononce bien.
Il va y avoir confusion.
Le nom de la tribu va être donné au tubercule
et l'artichaut d'hiver va devenir :
un topinambour.
Ce légume a été consommé jusqu'au XVIII ème siècle
avant d'être boudé au profit de la pomme deterre.
Les français l'ont redécouvert contre leur gré
sous l'occupation pendant la SecondeGuerre Mondiale
pour remplacer les pommes de terre
qui étaient alors réquisitionnées.
Puis,
il a denouveau été oublié avant de refaire surface.
On le retrouve depuis quelques années sur nos étals
du mois de novembre au mois d'avril.
Le topinambour contient un glucide dérivé du fructose,
l'inuline.
C'est pour cette raison
qu'après avoir consommé du topinambour
tout ce que l'on boit a un goût sucré.
Faites l'expérience, c'est très étonnant.
A bientôt !